Can you explain some possible symptoms of chronic H. Pylora in the infection?
So H. Pylora is helicobacter pylora, and I do have some posts on our website that go into detail and how to
care for it.
But this is a good question because I don't know that I go into detail with the symptoms though on some of the videos on those posts
I probably go into some of them, but
maybe not all the symptoms.
So symptoms of chronic, how would I know I have a chronic H. Pylora infection?
Well, the problem is this most of the time you won't.
So you could, you could have a chronic H. Pylora infection that's affecting your
blood vessels and not have, and your first symptom be a heart attack.
So that is an issue.
These silent infections, these chronic silent infections can be deadly.
So remember, you know,
atherosclerotic disease is not because of plaque build up in the arteries
or I should say the cause of plaque build up in the arteries
is it because of excess cholesterol?
It's because of damage to the arterial wall so that the endothelial layer of
cells that line the arterial walls, the vessel walls can become damaged
for a variety of reasons, excess homocysteine,
heavy metal toxicity, Lyme disease and H. Pylora.
So H. Pylora is one of the top five players in endothelial damage,
which leads to atherosclerosis, which leads to a heart attack.
So it also can lead to high blood pressure because H. Pylora bacteria
could get underneath the endothelial and damage the smooth muscle layer
as it adheres to different receptor sites in the smooth muscle.
And it causes contraction and it can lead to high blood pressure issues as well.
So many times when people have been diagnosed with high blood pressure,
they've been diagnosed with high cholesterol.
They've been there on medication for those things.
They've had issues with micro strokes or TIAs.
It's from a silent H. Pylora infection.
So if a person has known cardiovascular issues of any kind,
they should actually treat themselves as if they have an H. Pylora diagnosis
because it is very possibly the player or the root cause of those things.
But other common issues with chronic H. Pylora is rosacea type issues
so you could have like a hot and cold type flashes in the upper extremity.
You can have rashes on your arms.
You can have rashes on your neck and face.
Very common for those to be H. Pylora related.
You know, the symptoms can vary because H. Pylora goes systemic.
H. Pylora has a
common issue with endothelial issues,
that's vascular issues,
common cause of skin issues and the common cause of cancers.
So any of those should give you a red flag to maybe possibly treat four H. Pylora.
As far as how you would treat H. Pylora,
go into that more depth than some of the blog posts,
but the common killers of H. Pylora are going to be organ, grape, burburine,
oregano, garlic,
those are going to be your best killers of systemic H. Pylora or even H. Pylora in the gut.
And then work on healing the gut and balancing the microbiota on the gut.
But usually when you're talking about chronic H. Pylora infections,
it's gone systemic beyond the gut,
but it may have left damage and it got to treat that as well as important.